DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello.
My name's Dustin Kirkland.
I'm a product manager
at Google, and I'm
joined here by Lukas Heinrich.
He's a physicist at CERN and
has a pretty exciting experiment
that he reproduced
using cloud technology.
And he's going to tell
us a bit about that.
LUKAS HEINRICH: Yeah,
so during the keynote,
we rediscovered the Higgs boson
using a publicly available data
set.
And during a keynote, we
launched 25,000 workloads
on the public cloud to
analyze collision data
of the Large Hadron Collider.
And there, we
selected events where
we had a pretty good chance that
the Higgs boson was originally
there.
And during the keynote, you
could see a chart building up
where, in the
middle of the chart,
there was a small peak forming.
And that peak, more or
less, proved the existence
of the Higgs boson.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
That's fascinating.
So you work on
the ATLAS project.
And with the ATLAS project,
you're working on some data
from CERN.
And I understand this has
some parallels to what we do
in the open source community.
LUKAS HEINRICH: Right.
So many of the
experiments at CERN
have an open data policy,
which means that data
that we record, we
release it openly.
So I work with
the ATLAS project,
but the data that
we used in the demo
was from the CMS project,
which is a project that
is very similar to mine.
And it kind of
exemplifies that even
me, who is not a member
of the CMS project,
I can analyze this data from
them, because they released it
openly.
And in fact, thanks to
these cloud resources,
anybody can do it.
One of the challenges in open
data for these large scale
scientific
collaborations, is always
that the scale of the
data is very large.
And while we can release
it, it was always
a bit of a question of who
can practically analyze it
who doesn't have a data center.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And how
large is practically large?
LUKAS HEINRICH: The data
set we analyzed yesterday
in the span of a few
minutes was 70 terabytes.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: 70 terabytes.
It's not even practical for
me to download that and try
to store that at home on
a laptop in a university.
LUKAS HEINRICH: Exactly.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: But this can
be found now in the cloud.
LUKAS HEINRICH: Right.
So we have it available
at CERN, the open data.
And then we transfer it,
because we have high speed links
to the cloud providers.
We could transfer it into
Google Cloud Storage.
And this is from where we
read the data to analyze it.
And now anybody could,
in principle, do that.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So a
student, another university,
another organization,
anyone can work on that data
without downloading it.
LUKAS HEINRICH: Right.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: And where
do you see this going next?
Give us some idea of how
these methods and Google Cloud
can be used for your research.
LUKAS HEINRICH: So I think
what's super exciting,
is that this open data
originally oftentimes
was seen as something for
outreach or educational
purposes that you have
really small scale data sets,
but now researchers are
starting to really use it
for real scientific applications
outside of the experiments.
So people who have nothing to do
with the Large Hadron Collider,
they can analyze this data
that we release openly.
I think that is pretty exciting.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Cool.
And what's your next project?
LUKAS HEINRICH: So one thing
that I really want to try out
in the cloud ecosystem is
functions-as-a-service.
So this is something that kind
of fits well onto our work
that we showed yesterday.
And so we'll maybe get
back home and try that out.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah,
Cloud Run, Knative,
on top of Kubernetes.
LUKAS HEINRICH: Exactly.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Tell me a little bit
about your next project.
What are you working on next?
And how do you see
using Google Cloud?
LUKAS HEINRICH:
So I think what is
pretty exciting is the release
of Cloud Run a couple of weeks
ago.
And so the workload that
we showed yesterday during
the demo actually would
fit nicely into this
functions-as-a-service paradigm.
And maybe when we
get home, we'll
try this out and see whether we
can run the demo in this way.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah,
that's fascinating.
I would imagine those
batch-type services really match
to the work that you're doing.
LUKAS HEINRICH: It's all
the data transformations
where, so the data that we
download is in one form,
and then we process it and
produce a summary format.
And so this is
essentially a function.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND:
Thank you, Lukas.
I appreciate your time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]